et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
gabriel attal bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être la galerie à la tall porte parole
du gouvernement il vous est surtout là
en tant que soutien du candidat emmanuel
macron ce matin merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation pour
l'invitation on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes on intervient en partenariat
avec la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par fabrice veysseyre redon
du groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france fabrice monjournal et
gabriela talent on va parler de
l'ukraine évidemment puisque on a
entendu ce week-end le président
américain joe biden qualifié vladimir
poutine de boucher emmanuel macron a
réagi hier il dit qu'il n'aurait pas
employé ces mots est ce que joe biden
prend le risque de créer une escalade
dans ce conflit je n'ai pas à qualifier
les propos du président américain
ce qui est certain c'est que ce qu'on
recherche c'est évidemment une sortie du
conflit le président de la république se
mobilisent pour cela évidemment ça veut
dire toujours qualifié ce qui se passe
les exactions qui sont commises par les
troupes russes dire les choses en face
aussi à vladimir poutine pour ça qu'ils
échangent régulièrement continuer à
mettre la pression sur la russie
notamment en matière économique puis
continuer à apporter un soutien aux
ukrainiens en termes humanitaires et en
termes militaires une fois qu'on a dit
ça nous on ne cherche pas une escalade
nous ce qu'on cherche encore une fois
c'est une forme d'apaisement et la
sortie du conflit c'est pour ça que le
président de la république a tenu les
promesses que là il avait rappelé est ce
que là s'il prend le risque joe biden de
ruiner les efforts de dialogue des
machines a encore une fois moi je veux
pas
qualifié les propos des uns et des
autres ce qui est important encore une
fois c'est de chercher toujours dans nos
mots et dans nos actions la sortie du
conflit vous n'êtes pas de gouvernement
français vous il vous a pas échappé que
côté américain ils ont ils ont regardé
très très rapidement les propos du
président américain la semaine dernière
il ya eu un couac ou pas selon vous je
ne sais pas encore une fois en selle je
pense que il faut en permanence
retourner responsables politiques dans
un tel conflit chercher dans nos mots et
dans nos actions ce qui est utile à la
sortie du conflit ce qui est utile à la
sortie du conflit c'est d'agir encore
une fois en mettant une pression sur la
russie pour que le coût de la guerre
augmente et qu'à un moment la russie
soit contrainte de revoir ses plans et
ses calculs et d'y renoncer ce qui est
utile à la résolution du conflit c'est
de soutenir les ukrainiens qui ont fait
le choix courageux et héroïques de
résister en leur apportant un soutien en
matière humanitaire et en matière de
défense voilà moi je pense qu'il faut se
concentrer là dessus un mot quand même
sur emmanuel macron la situation se
qualifier de catastrophique situation
humanitaire qualifié de catastrophique
la mario paul-emmanuel mâcon doit
s'entretenir avec vladimir poutine pour
organiser des couloirs humanitaires
quand doivent-ils se parler et à ce que
les conditions de sécurité peuvent être
garanties pour assurer l'évacuation
décidée coûté que je crois pas que le
rendez vous était fixé mais c'est
aujourd'hui ou demain j'imagine puisque
le président vendredi a dit qu'il lui
parlerai dans les 48 72 heures
effectivement on a préparé avec la
turquie avec la grèce une opération
humanitaire pour évacuer des civils je
crois qu'il le reste cent cinquante
mille personnes aujourd'hui à marioupol
qui est une ville de quatre cent mille
habitants habituellement il y à des
habitants qui veulent fuir parce qu'ils
sont sous les bombes parce que les
images qui nous arrive de marioupol sont
des images de dévastation absolue parce
qu'ils la guérilla urbaine se poursuit
parce que les bombardements se
poursuivent aussi et donc il faut
permettre l'application du droit
humanitaire et permettre de protéger les
civils donc très concrètement nous avons
fait cette proposition aux opérations
humanitaires il ya eu un travail qui
s'est tenue ces derniers jours avec les
autorités ukrainiennes pour la préparer
et maintenant il faut convaincre la
russie vladimir poutine d'accepter cette
opération humanitaire c'est pour ça que
les chefs d'état vont échanger très
prochainement pour qu'elle puisse
aboutir nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est que
le siège soit levé que l'aide humaine
terre puisse arriver que les civils qui
souhaitent pouvoir fuir puisse le faire
train derniers mois sur ce qui se passe
en russie le groupe millet refuse de
quitter la russie malgré les demandes du
président ukrainien au groupe mulliez
chez auchan décathlon leroy merlin le
ministre des affaires étrangères le
crédit un appel au boycott d'auchan
compenser nous on a fixé avec les
partenaires européens avec les alliés un
certain nombre de sanctions quand on
fixe des sanctions on cherche encore une
fois un objectif qui est de renchérir le
coût de la guerre on n'a pas demandé aux
entreprises étrangères ce soit la france
où les autres pays de quitter la russie
en revanche qu'on leur a demandé est ce
qui est appliqué par les entreprises
françaises c'est de ne pas s'engager
dans de nouveaux investissements en
russie à partir de là ça devient une
décision de chaque entreprise il ya des
entreprises qui ont décidé de se retirer
de la russie on s'y est pas opposée pour
certaines entreprises là l'état français
et au conseil d'administration s'y est
pas opposé y en a de fait ce choix je
pense qu'elles font ce choix en se
posant plusieurs questions d'abord les
questions opérationnelles des questions
d'image de réputation aussi évidemment
et donc il appartient aux entreprises de
faire le show est injuste que les
ukrainiens le ministre des affaires
étrangères écrit appel au boycott d'une
entreprise française
encore une fois je vous ai dit je pense
que ma responsabilité de porte-parole du
gouvernement ça n'est pas de qualifier
des propos des uns et des autres il faut
beaucoup de sang froid dans cette crise
et je pense que notre responsabilité à
nous c'est de rechercher ce qui est
efficace et de pas voir entrer dans ce
type de débat ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il ya des entreprises françaises qui
sont en russie qu'elles font des choix
qu'elles doivent appliquer les sanctions
qui sont fixés et elles le font pour un
certain nombre d'entre elles les avaient
même devancé ce qu'ils avaient annoncé
qu'ils auraient pas d'investissements
supplémentaires avant même on leur
demande dans le cadre des sanctions et
ensuite elles elles prennent leurs
décisions en compétences moi je veux
rappeler que les sanctions qui ont été
prises à l'encontre de la russie elles
produisent des effets que les sanctions
massives qu'on a pu appliquer parce
qu'il ya une unité européenne parce que
les alliés aussi nous ont suivis elles
ont permis quoi elles ont permis que le
rouble chute elles ont permis que la
bourse de moscou soit fermée pendant
plusieurs semaines elles ont permis des
oligarques voient leurs actifs en dehors
la russie gelé ou saisies elles ont
permis des prises de position du coup
que ce soit dans l'église orthodoxe en
russie que ce soit le numéro 2 gaziers
russes des prises de position contre ce
conflit est donc ce qu'on cherche nous
encore une fois c'est que le coût de
cette guerre soit tellement élevés du
fait des sanctions que ça dure entre
guillemets du fait de la résistance des
ukrainiens que les autorités russes
finissent par se dire finalement ça ne
me coûte trop cher il faut qu'on revoie
nos calculs on espère que ça arrivera on
pense que c'est possible encore une fois
parce qu'on voit l'effet sur nos
sanctions c'est pour ça que les
sanctions doivent être appliquées il ya
des propos du président de la république
qui ont inquiété les françaises sur la
crise alimentaire sans précédent c'est
ce qu'il a dit la semaine dernière on a
conclu forcément la hausse des prix des
matières premières allaient entraîner
des hausses de prix est ce que si
emmanuel macron est réélu il y aura des
aides pour aider les français à faire
face à ces hausses de prix est ce qu'on
peut envisager un chèque alimentaires
non mais bien sûr mais d'abord on a
annoncé un certain nombre d' aide
independent a besoin de l'élection
présidentielle il ya un plan de
résilience qui a été annoncé par le
premier ministre qui comporte une
dimension agricole il faut bien
comprendre que la russie et l'ukraine
sont parmi les plus grands exportateurs
mondiaux de blé il ya d'autres produits
aussi qu'ils sont très concernés l'huile
de tournesol par exemple on a une chance
en france c'est qu'on est indépendant en
termes alimentaires ont produit notre
alimentation on a cette indépendance
cette souveraineté agricole c'est une
vraie chance et on le voit c'est même un
luxe quand on compare avec d'autres pays
dans le monde il ya donc ces tensions
d'approvisionnement au niveau mondial
sur cette question du blé par exemple et
donc il ya des pays très concrètement
notamment d'afrique subsaharienne qui
risque une pénurie et on sait que les
conséquences de ça c'est des drames
humanitaires c'est des famines et c'est
potentiellement des bouleversements
politiques majeures donc il faut agir à
l'international quand crise migratoire
par exemple car c'est évidemment
possible et donc c'est pour ça que le
président de la république a lancé un
mouvement à l'international pour obtenir
plusieurs choses d'abord qu'on puisse
libérer des stocks pour faire baisser la
tension sur les marchés au niveau
international ensuite qu'on puisse avoir
un mécanisme de solidarité un peu comme
on l'a fait sur les vaccins pendant la
crise qu vite vous vous souvenez on
avait mis en place un dispositif kovacs
au niveau européen pour doter des pays
pauvres en vaccins avec une solidarité
on veut faire la même chose s'agissant
du blé par exemple et c'est ce qui a été
lancé et puis enfin c'est investir pour
augmenter les capacités de production
des pays notamment africains qui encore
une fois ne sont pas autonomes
aujourd'hui en matière alimentaire ça
c'est pour l'international mais c'est
très important pour le niveau est dans
lé journal pour la france on est
producteur de blé est donc encore une
fois ce n'est pas une question de
d'approvisionnement ou de pénurie en
revanche on voit que les coûts
augmentent parce que la demande reste
réel au niveau mondial et que les
approvisionnements mondiaux du fait de
la situation en ukraine et en russie se
réduisent et donc ça peut avoir un
impact sur le prix à la fin notamment
parce que les éleveurs par exemple ont
besoin pour nourrir leur bétail de ces
matières premières et donc ce qu'on a
annoncé dans le cadre du plan de
résilience c'est par exemple une aide de
400 millions d'euros pour notre
agriculture pour faire en sorte que pour
les éleveurs les agriculteurs on puisse
compenser cette hausse des coûts de
production pour que ça se retrouve pas à
la fin sur la facture des français donc
c'est des mesures fortes à des aides
supplémentaires pour le porte monnaie
des français bah on a pris un certain
nombre d' aide sur la question
énergétique moi je veux rappeler à
blocage et sur la question alimentaire
le président de la république a dit
qu'il voulait aller vers ce chèque
alimentaires et donc effectivement dans
les prochains mois si les français nous
en donne la possibilité
on ira vers ce chèque alimentaires
notamment pour les ménages les plus
modestes pour qu'ils puissent se nourrir
compris en local autre question sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'est les prix à la
pompe un évidement qui inquiète là aussi
les français le gouvernement qui a
annoncé une remise
18 centimes sur le continent par litre
sur ses prix à la pompe que ça soit bien
clair cette baisse elle sera appliquée
dès vendredi dans toutes les stations
service oui absolument 1er avril c'est
ce qu'avait annoncé le premier ministre
c'est un système qui permet de compenser
en partie la hausse du coût de l'essence
pour les français on a déjà pris un
certain nombre de mesures je veux les
rappeler l'indemnité inflation tous les
français qui touchent moins de 2000
euros ils sont 38 millions ont reçu
cette aide exceptionnelle de 100 euros
on a relevé le plafond de l'indemnité
kilométrique pour les français qui
doivent beaucoup roulé notamment dans le
cadre de leur activité professionnelle
je pense par exemple aux infirmières
libérales qui doivent faire leur tournée
on sait qu'il ya un dispositif de frais
kilométriques qui leur est appliqué on a
relevé les barèmes pour compenser là
aussi cette hausse du prix de l'essence
et donc on a pris cette mesure pour
quatre mois de baisse de 18 centimes à
la pompe de ristourne de 10 centimes à
la pompe pour un litre d'essence on a
aussi demandé aux distributeurs
d'essence de participer à l'effort vous
avez par exemple total qui a annoncé
qu'ils ajouteraient une baisse de 10
centimes en plus des 18 centimes de
l'état aux livres d'autres distributeurs
qui ont annoncé aussi des mesures tout
ça doit nous permettre de tenir jusqu'à
ce qu'on met en place un dispositif qui
est véritablement ciblées vers les
français qui en ont le plus besoin c'est
à dire ceux qui roulent beaucoup qui
travaillent qui gagne peu on espère
pouvoir le président est vendredi
vendredi vous êtes vous allez faire
votre plein dans n'importe quelle
station service vous avez les bruits
sans la bâtir un système pour cela et on
apporte des garanties y compris pour des
stations par exemple qui ça devient un
peu technique mais qui remplissent leurs
cuves moins régulièrement que les
grandes stations parce qu'elles sont
moindres et l'intention certains
dispositifs d'avancés de trésorerie qui
sera fait pour qu'elle puisse appliquer
cette baisse dès le départ
et oui autre invité surprise de cette
campagne cette nouvelle vague de
couronnes un virus on voit le
réapparaître le masque dans plein
d'endroits les écoles les entreprises
est-ce qu'on a allégé le dispositif trop
tôt est ce que vous envisagez de revenir
à des mesures on a demandé beaucoup
d'efforts aux français depuis deux ans
avec des mesures et je pense que si les
français ont respecté les règles qu'on
fixe est et ont fait ces efforts c'est
parce qu'il savait quand on prenait des
mesures quand on mettait de nouvelles
règles c'est est impérieusement
nécessaire du fait de la situation à
l'hôpital et dons concédés toujours
engagé à lever nos mesures dès lors que
la situation de l'hôpital se serait
détendu et elle s'est beaucoup détendu
ces derniers mois c'est encore détendu
sur la semaine passée et aujourd'hui 150
patients de moins en réanimation
qu'ovide que la semaine dernière on est
repassé sous la barre des 1500 je crois
et donc c'est normal et c'est légitime
mais c'était attendu par les français on
assouplit c'est qu'on lève nos mesures
dès lors que la situation à l'hôpital
s'est amélioré à temps ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on constate en france comme peu
près partout en europe un rebond de
l'épidémie je crois pas qu'il soit lié
au fait qu'on ait assoupli les mesures
il avait d'ailleurs commencé un peu
avant par ailleurs on le constate dans
d'autres pays en europe y compris des
pays qui ont gardé des mesures qui ont
gardé par exemple port du masque partout
et donc là ce qu'on dit aux français
c'est oui on a levé ces mesures on a eu
raison de le faire on revient pas dessus
mais il faut évidemment garder une
vigilance notamment quand vous faites
partie des français fragile je pense aux
français âgés voire très âgées il faut
évidemment faire attention quand vous
allez dans des lieux où il ya beaucoup
de monde c'est vrai que porter le masque
ça permet quand même de vous protéger
faire un deuxième rappel quand vous avez
plus de 85 ans c'est aussi protecteur
parce qu'on sait que même si ce variant
omicron est beaucoup moins dangereux
entraîne beaucoup moins de forme grave
global pour des personnes très fragile
très âgées il peut rester dangereux donc
on a on a cet appel évidemment à la
responsabilité et à la vigilance mais
oui on a maintenu notre calendrier de
lever de rester le design le 10 avril
prochain des millions de français vont
se rendre aux urnes est ce que le masque
sera obligatoire dans les bureaux de
vote pour l'instant je crois pas que ça
a été fixée ou alors l'information m'a
échappé mais vous l'envisagez fait la
remontée des mois je ne veux pas dire
que exclure des choses par principe
aujourd'hui j'ai pas connaissance qu'on
ait pris une telle décision mais
évidemment pas dire qu'elle sera pas
pressé non évidemment les élections se
tiendront on a vu qu'on a pu tenir des
élections quand il y avait des vagues
très forte de coheed avec un protocole
sanitaire des protocoles seront oui bien
sûr entendre la direction locale donc là
on peut revenir à un protocole un peu
plus j'en ai encore une fois j'ai pas
d'informations à vous communiquer sur ce
sujet là mais un mot sur la corse oui
les situation s'est à nouveau tendue qui
avait atteint ce week-end en corse après
là diffusion notamment d'une vidéo de
militaires son temps là marseille espère
les obsèques dijon colonna
vous avez réagi comment assez assez
réaction d'hier soir notamment de ces
feux de vendée des compagnies on a vu il
ya effectivement à nouveau des tensions
très fortes qui se sont heureusement en
fin de soirée je crois vers 23h arrêtés
qui ont cessé et je crois qu'on déplore
un bilan au global de 7 blessés légers
évidemment amener ces arrestations ouais
je veux c'est crs et les manifestants
évidemment nous notre souhait c'est que
l'apaisement revienne le calme que
l'ordre revienne pour qu'on puisse
échanger
gouvernement exécutif corse sur toutes
les questions relatives à la corse cette
ville et cette vidéo vous choque ou pas
quelle vidéo cette vidéo qui a été
diffusée c'est de serrer chantant la
marseillaise je n'ai pas de j'ai pas vu
pour les jeunes entendu parler des eaux
non authentifiée
je sais par an dans une caserne mais
mais son continent les obsèques d yvan
colonna dit ce qui est important c'est
que on puisse avoir le calme avoir
l'ordre l'apaisement pour pouvoir avoir
ces discussions ces négociations pour
pouvoir avancer sur tous les sujets qui
préoccupent et qui a serré vous voyez
que les tensions et continue et
finalement c'est possible aujourd'hui
c'est impossible à quelles conditions
est ce que c'est vers ce nouveau pas
c'est possible parce que il ya eu une
rencontre entre le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin et
l'exécutif corse s'est rendu sur place
pendant près de trois jours est qu'à
l'issue de ces trois jours des changes
il ya eu une forme d' accord de méthode
qui a été signé entre les deux et que on
a du coup un calendrier de discussions
de réunion de travail sur les questions
institutionnelles sur les questions
économiques corse qui devra qui doivent
démarrer je crois au début du mois
d'avril et qui vont se poursuivre en un
mot juste sur les cabinets de conseil
avant de parler de la campagne des
manuels macro emmanuel macron a redit
hier qu'il voulait la transparence sur
les cabinets de conseil privé en rien un
rapport du sénat qui a beaucoup fait
parler près d'un milliard qui ont été
dépensés l'année dernière pour des
recours à ces cabinets de conseil privé
est ce que dans le prochain quinquennat
vous vous engagez à avoir moins recours
à ces cabinets de conseils pour vous
d'abord on n'a pas attendu le prochain
quinquennat pour fixer un cadre je
rappelle qu'en 2018 on a rappelé à tous
les ministères le cadre sur les marchés
publics sur les règles etc il ya eu la
crise sanitaire où il ya eu une
augmentation du recours au cabinet de
conseil c'était les amis des arts vous
comprenez que c'est ça me choque c'est
une réalité on était dans un contexte de
crise historique où vous avez besoin de
mobiliser toutes les forces ça s'est
fait dans tous les pays est important
c'est de revenir à à
un recours plus normal de rythme de
croisière au cabinet de conseil et donc
on va voir que ces dernières années oui
on n'a pas attendu le prochain
quinquennat puisque ma collègue émilie
de montchalin ministre de l'action la
transformation public qui en charge de
ce sujet là a annoncé sur 2022 une
baisse de déjà de 15 % des dépenses
liées au cabinet de conseil maintenant
moi je vous le rappeler les cabinets de
conseils ça fait très longtemps que
l'état ya recours en france que des
collectivités y ont recours en france
des régions des mairies des départements
que tous les pays du monde y ont recours
l'important c'est que ça se fasse avec
mesure et que surtout ça correspondent à
des besoins des pouvoirs publics sur des
compétences sur des missions par exemple
qui n'existe pas dans l'état ont fait
beaucoup pour avoir des compétences des
missions supplémentaires dans l'état n'a
fait une réforme de la haute fonction
publique pour diversifier les profils et
parcours dans la haute fonction publique
pour que des personnes il vient du privé
puissent venir travailler dans la
fonction publique a porté aussi leurs
expériences leurs compétences mais quand
vous n'êtes quand vous et un projet une
mission qui nécessitent d'adjoindre des
experts qui ont une expérience qui
peuvent apporter quelque chose à l'état
oui faut y avoir au cours moi je fais
pas partie de ceux qui considèrent que
l'état par principe et omniscient
omnipotent évidemment et d'ailleurs on a
vu dans la crise sanitaire aussi qu'en
dehors de l'état il pouvait y avoir des
initiatives privées qu'ils pouvaient
venir renforcer l'efficacité on a vu par
mme sur les vaccins tous ces sites qui
ont été mis en place vite ma dose kovy
de liste etc qui permettait à partir des
données et des informations qui étaient
communiqués par l'état de rendre plus
accessible un certain nombre de choses
aux français moi je trouve ça très
positif quand vous avez en dehors de
l'état des personnes qui vient de
s'engager pour l'intérêt général un mot
sur une réforme qui a fait beaucoup
parler une des mesures du programme des
manuels mâcon qui fait beaucoup parler
c'est la réforme des retraites le chef
de l'état qui dit qu'il passera à l'âge
légal à 65 ans sur une durée de neuf ans
et progressif il a bien expliqué mais un
mot sur le calendrier il sera présenté
quant aux projets d'ouest que ça fait
partie de vos priorités est ce que ça
sera présenté d'ici l'été ce qu'a dit le
président de la république plutôt le
candidat emmanuel macron en l'espèce
c'est qu'il souhaitait après son
élection si les français lui en donne le
mandat lui font confiance lancer des
discussions des négociations avec les
partenaires sociaux je crois pas qu'il
ait fixé de calendrier fixe dans
l'émission à laquelle il anticipe
que ça sera tout à la rentrée c'est
toute l'année ce qu'ils voulaient
essayer disent que les discussions
puissent commencer maintenant vous savez
si vous voulez discuter de manière
ouverte et constructive avec les
partenaires sociaux fixer d'ores et déjà
une borne à la discussion je suis pas
sûr que ça permette cela donc nous ce
qu'on souhaite c'est que cette réforme
est depuis s'être fait on pense qu'elle
est nécessaire pour le pays moi je veux
rappeler quand même qu'on a un système
qui est financé par des actifs qui
travaillent qui payent les retraites et
des pensions des retraités qu'on a de
plus en plus de retraités parce que
l'espérance de vie s'allonge
donc on a progressivement un déficit qui
se creuse de notre système que si on
fait rien à la fin on pourra plus payer
les retraites et donc il ya trois choix
qui sont possibles pour rééquilibrer les
choses soit vous baisser les pensions
des retraités on refuse de le faire soit
vous augmenter les cotisations les
impôts sur ceux qui travaillent pour
pouvoir financer les pensions des
retraités on refuse de le faire aussi
soit vous demandez aux personnes qui
travaillent de travailler un peu plus
longtemps évidemment pas tous dans les
mêmes conditions évidemment en tenant
compte de la pénibilité des carrières
moment là dessus ça ça on n'a pas très
bien compris de quelle manière il sera
tenu compte de la pénibilité c'est
précisément ce qu'on doit construire
avec les partenaires sociaux c'est pour
ça qu'on veut une discussion une
concertation avec eux ne s'est pas fixé
il doit y avoir une réintroduction des
critères de pour vous tenir et on en
bave parce que ce qu'on ne veut pas
c'est recréer des régimes spéciaux vous
même les supprimer et notamment
supprimer les deux principaux régimes
spéciaux ratp edf on a déjà supprimé
celui de la sncf pour les nouveaux
entrants on va faire la même chose pour
les nouveaux entrants à edf et à la ratp
parce que c'est pas normal on considère
que un chauffeur de bus à paris par
rapport à un chauffeur de bus dans
d'autres villes françaises alors qu'ils
font le même travail qu'ils ont la même
rémunération celui de paris puisse
partir jusqu'à cinq ans je crois avant
les autres c'est pas juste je pense pas
que les français soutiennent ce type
entre la pénibilité c'est la discussion
avec les partenaires sociaux rien n'est
oublié sur l'application en revanche
qu'on dit c'est qu'il sera tenu compte
de la pénibilité qui sera tenu compte
des carrières longues ce que vous avez
des personnes qui ont commencé à
travailler à 17 18 19 20 ans évidemment
il faut qu'elles puissent partir avant
les autres et donc il y aura cette prise
en compte pour faire pour leur permettre
de partir avant la fin mais aussi sur
une question celle des collectivités
emmanuel macron une lettre au maire de
nanterre qu'il a besoin d'eux les
collectivités quelle contribution vous
attendait d'elle pendant le prochain
quinquennat et ce qu'elles seront mises
à contribution à hauteur de combien la
première contribution qu'on attend des
collectivités et des élus c'est qu'ils
participent aux grands chantiers qui ont
été ouverts par le candidat emmanuel
macron quand on parle de revoir
complètement la façon dont fonctionne
notre école pour que ça soit plus
efficace et ce quoi ça réduise encore
davantage les inégalités évidemment on a
besoin des élus locaux quand on parle de
la santé de la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux évidemment on a besoin et avec
les élus locaux quand on parle de
renforcer l'insertion dans l'emploi des
français en créant france travail c'est
à dire en faisant en cassant les silos
qui existe aujourd'hui évidemment que ça
nécessite de travailler avec les élus
locaux contre parce que vous allez venir
le mot d'ordre de notre campagne c'est
avec vous avec vous c'est évidemment
être les français c'est aussi avec les
élus c'est avec toutes les forces vives
de la nation qu'on doit construire les
solutions et c'est ça qu'on le croyait
que le prêt le candidat emmanuel macron
a dit dans sa lettre a rappelé dans sa
lettre aux élus ensuite parce qu'elle
est pas question d'économie dans la
lettre est ce que oui ou non on s'assied
dans la lah des économies de fait dans
la lettre et dans le programme ce qu'on
dit c'est qu'il ya aujourd'hui une
trajectoire de dépenses qui est fixé par
l'état par la sécurité sociale par les
collectivités locales et que ce qu'on
souhaite pour l'état pour la sécurité
sociale pour les collectivités locales
c'est qu'évidemment elle soit contenue
modéré voilà et parce qu'à la fin il ya
un seul contribuable qui paye il ya une
seule dette à rembourser et donc c'est
ça qui a été rappelé par treize ans la
république tout en laurent saint martin
devant des élus par les un chiffre de 10
milliards oui vraiment il faut qu'on
tire les leçons tout en rappelant tout
en rappelant qu'il y aura la
sanctuarisation des dotations aux
collectivités locales vous savez moi je
me souviens en 2017 on faisait campagne
pour emmanuel macron et on avait on
s'était engagé à ce que les dotations
aux collectivités soient sanctuarisés on
avait à ce moment là je me souviens des
élus qui le disaient on a vu une saignée
dans nos dotations dans le quinquennat
qui vient de s'écouler est ce que
vraiment vous allez tenir votre
engagement on a tenu notre engagement il
a été tenu et donc qu emmanuel macron
dit que les dotations seront
sanctuarisés mais vous demanderez dans
l'économie mais on ne demandera à l'état
à la sécurité sociale aux collectivités
de faire un effort non pas de dépenser
mois mais deux que l'augmentation des
dépenses se fasse de manière modérée
voilà c'est quand même
c'est un effort qui paraît tout à fait
soutenable ses congénères question fasse
pas au détriment au contraire de la
qualité de service pour les français
dernière question sur ce qui s'est passé
hier lors du meeting bien évidemment il
est au trocadéro pendant 10 secondes
des soutiens d'eric zemmour scandant
macron assassins devant des images de
victimes notamment du terrorisme eric
zemmour dit mme pas les avoir entendus
vous en pensez-quoi
savez moi je soutiens un candidat
emmanuel macron qui a toujours rappelé
dans ses meetings c'était le cas en 2010
est je pense ce sera encore le cas il ya
un meeting important à à paris qui se
tient samedi prochain qui a toujours
appelé à la bienveillance qui a refusé
qu'on siffle ou qu'on eut ses
adversaires et là vous voyez un candidat
qui laisse des militants proférer des
propos absolument insupportable à
l'encontre d'un autre candidat je pense
que c'est à ça qu'on juge aussi les
hommes quand ils candidate à l'élection
présidentielle qui est une fonction dont
moi j'ai pu voir aux côtés du président
de la république combien elle nécessite
du calme du sang-froid et oui de la
bienveillance soyez soir eric zemmour ne
tient pas n'a pas d'autorité sur ses
militants soit ils cautionnent ce type
de propos dans les deux cas c'est assez
inquiétant sur la capacité à sur sa
capacité à exercer les fonctions
président de la république encore voir
écouter ça c'est les français qui en
décident
c'est les français qui votent et qui
décide qui est le mieux placé pour
présider notre pays mais bon moi je
rappelle encore une fois que nous on
s'est toujours battu et on continuera à
se battre pour la bienveillance en
politique parce que la réalité c'est que
quand on tient des propos inacceptables
sur un candidat qui appellent à la
violence quand on laisse tenir des
propos inacceptables sur un candidat qui
appellent à la violence faut pas
s'étonner derrière qui est de la
violence contre les élus faut pas
s'étonner derrière qui est de
l'attention qu'il puisse y avoir des
agressions et donc il faut jamais
laisser passer ce type de propos merci
cavaliers à la tâche merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin en
tant que soutien du candidat emmanuel
macron
[Musique]